time's running out for the phenic arms a
country Pub that thinks it's claridges
is this Pub fruit
because I can't quite believe I'm
standing in the traditional English pub
this week I'm trying to help the most
stubborn fruitcake I've ever met I love
Bates now where did that one come from
seven days to teach this old dog some
new tricks just remember we are the
bosses it will take a miracle
come and tell me yeah because I'll smash
them over your head
[Music]
oh
balloon Valley a wealthy farming area in
the heart of the Lancashire Countryside
home of the hot pot and the custard tart
are a great location for a roadside Pub
so I'm looking for the fennec arms
a good old traditional English pub every
day thousands of punters speed past the
pub they slap bang on the busy a683
between Lancaster and Kirby Lonsdale
foreign
's favorite place to eat out and Brian
Ray has spent the last 30 years cooking
pub food
I don't claim to be God I don't claim to
be Jesus but in my business and in my
kitchen my word is law
there's a meant to be made if you get
pub food right but since Brian and his
partner Elaine Howden took over the
phenic arms three years ago they've been
hemaging money at a rate of 1500 quid a
week
what's going on there
one big overgrown bush
me yeah yeah is the menu
okay
this is Elaine Elaine nice to see and
hello I'm Brian Brian how are you oh I'm
fine good delighted to meet you likewise
good to see you very delighted God it's
tight in here isn't it yep so where's
the um where's the restaurant dining
area is this way follow us down there
this is supposed to be a traditional
English pub but it's full of tacky
clutter and when it comes to table
settings Brian's got serious delusions
of grandeur
foreign
[Music]
not what I imagined as a pub
um we used to have this just as a small
dining room with four tables in it God
looks like they've got the queen coming
for dinner no
unfortunately no one's coming for dinner
but it's not for want of trying Brian
and Elaine are throwing everything at
this failing business we spend most of
our life down here anything between 100
and 120 hours a week down here 120 hours
a week 60 hours each yeah
120 each
one day we don't if you don't take that
we had we had Christmas day off this
year it was your last day off
yep and the day before that was the
previous Christmas and the day before
that would have been about 18 years ago
Jesus I'm six days off for a heart
bypass
but I was back at work on the seventh
day
you're back at work seven days later yep
seven days after the auction I was back
working in the kitchen cooking
are you mad probably how old are you 62
62.
Christ
Brian is killing himself over an empty
Pub this place should feel laid back and
Lively but it's got all the formality
and awkwardness of awake
it stays you know the atmosphere is
static and very and dreary
serving you for this evening thank you
plus the additions of the day care for a
wife
Brian calls them additions rather than
specials doesn't like to call them
specials
I see but it's far from being a pub man
using the god red Johnson's cornfield
goose in our duck breasts Rebel
Farmhouse savoy cabbage roasted potato
Willington crispy Apple Chinese
Brian's trying way too hard and his list
of pompous sources is ridiculous I mean
there's pure Merlot red wine sauce juice
kavlo juice Lancaster's use caramelized
onions tartar
extraordinary
you walk into a pub and you expect a
distinctively pudding shepherd's pie
I've ordered the simplest thing on the
menu a prawn salad but Brian doesn't do
simple
we'd like to point out
first and foremost we're a traditional
Old English pub
that's Steven tradition there isn't it
let's see if Brian can get traditional
with my main course but I'm doubtful
it's Cocker and rack of lamb balsamic
cherry tomatoes and one of those
pretentious sauces how the do you
get in how do you get the lamb out
not only is this not pub food but it's
plain awful
honestly it's like chewing a
golf ball
Brian's got a lot to answer for
this is a pub isn't it yes and that's
what I have to keep on telling myself a
traditional Old English pub
so how many pubs have you been in
that have served a over-reduced syrupy
sickly bathroom with vinegar in a zed
shape over a square plate
probably not
a pub or Pub grub is the next step up
from from home now is that basic rustic
honest good British solid food and
there's nothing traditional about what
you're doing here
this is currently running as a
restaurant that is confused
over the top
I mean absurd beyond belief
you're not running a pub
it feels like you're running a
restaurant
badly
modern pub food is all about simple home
cooking done well but I don't think it's
going to be easy persuading Brian and
Elaine that they need to get back to
basics how you feeling
totally crap
it was pretty devastating last night
um some of the things yes we could fully
accept and take
um but be quite honest the way we felt
if you have to be like that to get to
the top I'm glad I'm at the bottom
I've got to be brutally honest clearly
you don't like that level of honesty I'm
not here for a confrontation and you
know if you're that devastated on the
back of what you've been through in this
industry for 30 years I'm surprised
you're so weak
after 30 years hard graft Brian and
Elaine should be reaping the benefits
but in fact they're facing bankruptcy
and could be homeless in three months
they've got to face facts how much are
you in there
when we actually sat down and wrote it
down
tossed it all up uh put everything into
it well you sort of leave things out so
that you don't see it uh we're about
quarter of a million in there if we had
to close tonight
the situation at the clinic arms is
desperate I need to find out how Brian
runs his kitchen
since he's heart op his memory lets him
down so he sets a timer for every dish
he's cooking and that helps you not to
forget when it's ready but it's not just
that it's getting an awareness all the
time that time's passed so how many
times have you got going on just one at
the moment
three times
[Music]
Ryan's short-term memory is as awful as
the rich sticky sources coating every
dish
and this one and that I believe is a
previous copy reduction
um we actually didn't have a lot of
cider so it's a scrumpy Direction
without the scrumpy appetized reduction
with apple ties in there
Apple ties
me I feel sick
I'm starting to realize nothing about
this kitchen makes sense have you got
any Mash ready for us Nate
and we've got a bowl for that
while Brian runs around the tiny cram
space he's paying top whack to his most
experienced Chef Nathan who seems to
just put pass in everything
this is normal it's normal
I've never seen such a chaotic and
inefficient kitchen and on top of that
there's Brian's over complicated and
frankly ridiculous food Stone Cold
lettuce piping hot pigeon red wine sauce
hey you got a brain haven't you
I hope so yeah I like to think so is
this pug food no because I can't quite
believe I'm standing in a
traditional English pub
Brian's already had five heart attacks
and he's running himself into the ground
cooking the wrong food in the wrong way
your kitchen is a disaster Zone it is
impossible to get food out of
there
I tell you what big boy you may be 62
but me you'd have to work that hard
you know that
'd be nice if I didn't I I swear to God
because that must be a nightmare
in there
the phenic arms in Lancashire has ideas
above its station
it's a country pub with aspirations to
be a fancy restaurant the dining room is
set for the queen and the food is
pretentious
Brian Ray and Elaine Howden are over a
quarter of a million pounds in debt but
they're still spending
you've got a setup of a restaurant big
coffee machine espresso
expensive bit of quit this no
I've picked up for 400 pounds 400 quid
yeah you bought it yeah from where eBay
eBay yeah
Brian stuffed his kitchen with so much
second-hand equipment you can't swing a
cat let me just squeeze past here thanks
you're small you know that oh it's
an outset of time I know we that's what
you do you look for chefs on eBay look
at their size their measurement their
weight then employ them yes
Brian's DIY kitchen is a cramped botched
together disaster Zone held together
with bits of string
and his holding problem goes much deeper
than I first thought
I I love plates whereas other people
will go and have a holiday or go out for
a meal I'll save my pennies and buy a
plate
Jesus me look all those plates
there wrapped in them from why they
wrapped in clinfield stay clean
just stay clean yeah
right
what are these plates used for
just some I bought to play with
somebody bought to play with yeah we
haven't played with them yet just got
the chance of getting them so I got them
what do you think they're putting there
salad will come up with some addition
use them for that
no no no no no come on you don't serve
food in them do you yes we did oh no
come on I wouldn't put dog's
dinner in there you don't serve food in
there uh we have done in the past no
look at the size of it
they're big I mean you you can you can
go tiling with that thing you know that
we can re-tile this whole establishment
with these plates just look what we can
start doing in terms of look
already starting to look unique isn't it
yep and so you said what what Chinese
dish on this one it wasn't it was a
Japanese dish
the tile glue didn't stick
sorry don't worry it was chipped anyway
damn damn damn damn
every corner I turn I discover another
of Brian's stashes squealed away
now where did that one come from
I bought that from pillar I bought
okay now and what's that you don't serve
food on that come on yes we do it's like
a swimming pool for Barbie
now we've got one with three
compartments down the side we should
have the stake on that you serve the
steak on that yep
a lifetime of hoarding calls for shock
treatment
before I can even think about changing
the food I've got to make some space
condemned broken chipped skipped yeah
yeah this where did you get this thing
from
eBay eBay
tucked away in the corner Ryan's got a
huge disgusting stockpot it's the base
for all these revolting sources that's
going to go in the skip
we don't need to have the Shiraz
the Merlot we don't need it that for me
is a hazard
do we need that hot plate
um well it's usually a way of keeping
the food hot
Brian's been collecting kitchen
equipment for 30 years he's never thrown
anything away and even with me here to
help is finding it difficult
bit of a shock to the system
it's a hell of a shot to the system some
of these items they're going to keep
some of them here you're going to sell
and something you're going to Chuck
printed tag on there left to his own
devices I know Brian would put all this
junk back so I'm forcing him to decide
how much of it is actually essential to
running the kitchen I don't want to get
rid of that yet there I just want to
keep that top it's a table top you don't
want to get rid of that oh dear he's
hopeless keep them because I have to
find somewhere for them how many
microwaves do you need let's get one or
two three what do you do with three
microwaves one one and one spare I've
been trying to get rid of some of this
rubbish for two or three years but Brian
will not bow with anything
I'm leaving Elaine in charge of
rebuilding the kitchen while I make sure
that Brian's junk has gone for good
okay we'll see that skip behind there
that's full of your junk
and I'm really worried the fact that
you're gonna put half that junk back in
your kitchen so I've got to get rid of
it once and for all
come on get that stockpile away
we're getting rid of the sheds
look at it
stop holding crap
I think you're well and truly made the
point
the harsh truth is that 20 rural pubs
close every month and if Brian and
Elaine don't want to add to that number
they need to start making some drastic
changes
got a huge amount of respect for
Brian the guy's 62 years of age he's
been cooking for 30 years he hasn't got
a pot to piss him he's working
in excess of 120 hours of week
in the kitchen I'm sorry but for any man
at 62.
that can kill you
clearing out the junk was just the
beginning
before I can start changing that
god-awful food I need to get this
kitchen working properly
basically got here like
I'm here in a minute
I've got to do something drastic
I need to clear out one final thing from
the kitchen
Brian
wait for you tonight don't be scared of
a change you're not cooking in the
kitchen tonight you are out of the
kitchen for good
and you're more capable of running your
Pub but not from the kitchen
has a proper Publican as a proper host
I will do my best please go and get
changed I will
I think this kitchen's got a better
chance without Brian he's got a young
but enthusiastic team of Three Chefs
Nathan Karen and Chris I know how
difficult Brian is to work with that is
so obvious yeah he's gone now
yeah he's not running the kitchen he's
running his business
show him that you can do it
essential that the fenik arms has a
friendly couple out front
but I'm not convinced Brian will be up
to the job after 30 years behind the
stove
did anybody tell you we've run out of
sea bass and we've only got one TM left
right anybody any ideas on what you're
looking for before we run out of
what's left
oh dear not exactly a polished
performance
that way talk to them Brian they won't
bite
but it's looking much more professional
in the kitchen where Karen has taken
charge
don't worry about drizzing the plate
just Source the thing please
there you go
good
[Applause]
even with Brian's complicated menu the
food is flying out of the kitchen just
like it should do in a pub
they're doing a great job in there now
the problem's in the dining room and
there's no vibrant set
the atmosphere is stuffy and formal why
on Earth is he laying pouring the wine
this is supposed to be a pub
[Music]
while Brian and Elaine fuss over their
customers their empty tables in the
dining room and the bar is filling up
with people waiting to eat
[Music]
they're never going to make a profit
running it like this I need to fill the
tables twice a night
what's happening in the bar everyone's
sitting in there taking orders get them
straight to the table get them
in the restaurant clear the bar
can I pass you some menus are these
ladies
Ryan has got to loosen up or they'll
never speed up the service
I mean really well done my problem was
in the dining room
your service doesn't need to be that
formal if you relax the service relax
and that's not nitpicking we're a pub
yeah what's wrong with them carrying
their own drinks through to the table
you know yourself why the atmosphere is
not right you know it's not running
smoothly of course you do but we need to
work on that level of just
I've only got three days to go and I've
still got to solve the biggest problem
at the fenugar arms Brian's food
what is traditionally
English pub food what is it
but I suppose English pub food is
basically scampi Gammon sausage
that but that isn't what I want to be
that's nothing of A Sort me what
pubs have you been in
um not quite so many since I ended up in
one myself
it's rustic
simple English cooking
whether it's a bowl of
split pea soup whether it's a Lancashire
hot pot
whether it's steak and chips it is
simple food
and that's where I've lost my way then
it's time I push Brian in the right
direction
see this on here
twaddle yeah absolute horrendous waffle
I don't want to see the madeira's sauce
the Citrus mayonnaise I don't want to
see a Calvary no more sauces the pub
will be serving Great British pub food
I've got to start replacing some of
Brian's dishes with good home cooking
yeah yeah
what's wrong with having lunch Shopper
on the menu nothing at all when are we
Lancashire and so why is that not on the
menu
I've asked Brian and Elaine to rewrite
the menu minus the waffle pan fried duck
with us
just
fried duck livers
fish tank
um just put it down fish cake
potatoes on top lots of potatoes yeah
spread nice good
give a little twist at the bottom like
that that mixes the onions and the
potatoes yeah up on top
and in what have you done for the fish
cake salmon
had a fish cake
salmon and haddock fish cake yeah and
that's it yep wow
finally we're getting somewhere I feel
like we're really starting to
understand what Pub means
progress at last but I don't think they
really understand what a pub is until
they've been to one
so I'm giving them the night off their
first Saturday Night Out in 18 years
good uh right Elaine
uh Brian
take the dogs for a walk
don't worry about the service
right when you come back okay
get changed yeah and come and have
dinner when was the last time you sat in
here on a Saturday night and watched
your staff at work and enjoyed your
dinner never right okay
off you go thank you guys see you later
thank you see you later right now one
last thing
you're the only Pub in Britain that's
got a uniform get change into
your service see you in five minutes
ready to run the place yeah
[Music]
I'm hoping that if Brian and Elaine
experience a real Pub atmosphere they'll
realize relaxed is best so tonight
there'll be no fussy service at the
fenik arms
good evening
how are you
uh
you can't come in
you too busy no we're not too busy um
you're not here to receive an OB you're
here to have dinner you're dressed too
formal we'll go back again as quick as
you can right lovely
we've never been out ever not dressed
like this right come back with something
casual
[Music]
welcome to the thinning arms come
through please
[Music]
tonight they'll be sampling the first of
my new real Pub grub not a sticky zoo in
sight it's a rather nice color
it's good
that that
is to die for
food has been a hit I Hope they've
finally got the message that they've got
nothing to fear from going back to
basics
and you can do it I'm getting you out of
this place today was a breath of a share
just to relax the place and the more you
can relax I swear to God you're going to
see your business grow
last night was a success
I thought the fenig arms was back on
track
but this morning I've discovered Brian
had gone behind my back and jeopardized
everything we've been trying to achieve
we had a really good night last night
and the staff worked
exceptionally well um so after I left
um Brian came downstairs and started
being a cantankerous old bat
and right I'm just gonna have a word
with him yeah in fact both of them
because I'm getting a little bit
pissed off a minute my back's turn and
then what is a complaining to you this
morning
um it's generally that um he doesn't
want to see any of his plates being
binned he doesn't want anything being
different he came around took all his
knives out
um it was just generally
um this is our business this is our home
things aren't going to be changing as
much as everybody thinks we're still
going to be doing it our way and
nobody's missed any difference and
what's stuck in his ways I'm pissed off
really yeah what happened let's go one
to ten yeah
give me a good seven
unbelievable two days to go and he
decides to screw it all up
at 62 years of age it's becoming really
clear that you can't teach an
old dog new tricks
I'm nearing the end of my week at the
fenik arms where I'm trying to save
Brian and Elaine from the jaws of
bankruptcy
I thought we'd turn the corner Ryan's
gone behind my back and told his staff
he won't accept my changes
I want to get it out with you now
because I don't mind going I'd rather go
and see my wife today and sit here and
bang my head against the wall
if you're not prepared to accept the
changes
you've got to tell me and the nitpicking
do you know what you've got to balance
it out with some confidence and a little
bit of encouragement as we I said in
this this morning right just remember we
are the bosses it's not a power struggle
you are definitely the owners just cut
them a little snack you'll be surprised
you know what we're acting like small
children aren't we thank you they're
busting their nuts off for you right now
they're busting their nuts off for you
right now that's not for me that's for
you because you pay their
salaries not me and when you're worried
about your villain what place
that no one's changing come and
tell me yeah because I'll smash them
over your head
okay
they better have listened this time I'm
only here for two more days and a bigger
concern is that it's Sunday on a bank
holiday weekend and the pub is virtually
empty
and Sunday lunch normally this quiet or
Sunday lunch is some weeks you can have
quite a few in other words
so turning here we are sat at quarter
two 25 kilos done and then we should be
having a second seating coming in now
for Sunday lunch
thank God only 25 people are going to
eat the miserable looking roast they're
serving today
it's coated in yet another disgusting
brown sauce
is that Brian's recipe yeah
it's a revolting concoction of gravy
granules and reduced red wine
I may have kicked Brian out of the
kitchen but unfortunately his influence
still lingers on
I suppose you can always retail
the roof on that can't we look at
that
me why is it so dark
but the Yorkshire puddings are actually
pretty impressive what a shame they're
going to be ruined by Brian's disgusting
gravy why isn't this place packed out
for a Sunday lunch we don't know
we just don't know
we have no idea it's
um
we've tried different menus we've had
bigger we've had shorter we've tried all
sorts yeah but
look how busy the road is yeah
yeah I've been ramming them in
Sunday lunch yep
turnover needs to increase by at least
two thousand pound a week I think Sunday
lunch holds the key to solving the
problem
but there's only one thing Brian's gravy
is good for
yeah we're saying goodbye to the group
hello to gravy
[Music]
[Applause]
one thing we'll do now is make a proper
gravey yes when's the last time you made
a proper gravy uh years ago years ago
yeah fresh all in there yeah and carrots
leaks
celery yeah yeah
and it's really important to make the
gravy in the tray the meat was roasted
in
and now the stock
beef stock yeah bring that up to the
boil
right and when I when I pass this
through a sieve I want to see the bottom
of the tray
yeah yeah nice and clean yeah
what happens all the vegetables start to
go through the sieve so it naturally
thickens the gravy
out and look
gravy
this has given me a great PR idea that's
going to appeal to Brian's eccentric
personality and give the fenugar arms
the Boost it so desperately needs
that was an overview business was it you
know and we took how much
60 something 400 quiz one two three four
five six seven eight eight was on the
barely enough to pay the wages
belly enough yeah the penny dropped for
me today you know why can't this place
become famous
for gravy
brilliant idea look at these things
they're amazing you've got the amazing
potential to have a fantastic Sunday
lunch
bring back real gravy this place will be
heaving
yes how you go you get on the streets
and you just announced okay that
you you've got a campaign to launch real
gravy at the thinning arms yes a
campaign to launch real gravy hey it
sounds a little bit but why
can't you just turn it around and get
out on the street with the team yeah yes
give us a word yes we will launch the
campaign
foreign
is well and truly sold on the campaign
join the campaign for real gravy join
the fenik arms for real gravy
the troops are armed with Yorkshire
puddings and jugs of gravy and we're
ready to hit the streets of Kirby
Lonsdale
[Music]
what's up
real gravy there we are
[Music]
sauces
just real traditional British gravy
the campaign for real gravy starts at
the medical Captain the center of the
universe for real gravy nice
baby
[Applause]
great Word of Mouth publicity is
unbeatable and Brian and the team have
done a brilliant job making damn sure
the fenik arms is the Talk of the Town
not just any gravy but the real gravy
we relaunched tomorrow and one word
spreads about the real gravy the pub
should be packed out
join our campaign real gravy
my last day
still a lot to do before tonight's
relaunch
First Impressions count so there's no
point launching a big PR campaign if the
place looks a dump when the punters get
here
have a look at that sign it cheapens the
place
I want to see the feeling arms so that
Banner you know that's got to go and the
whole place just needs sprucing up a
little bit so jet hose the front and
just get it nice and vibrant
[Music]
while the front of house teams spruce up
the exterior I've suggested to Brian
that he gets back on eBay and starts
selling off his huge Crockery collection
[Music]
I've got 10 of those and they're
starting off at 46 good each
I may have done the impossible and got
Brian selling his plates but I've got a
feeling he won't find staying out the
kitchen so easy I need Elaine to keep an
eye on him when I'm gone
there's one person that can make sure
that he doesn't go back to his old ways
is you
yeah I shall I shall remind him
I think he'll listen you've got to keep
him
keep him out of that kitchen you cannot
let him back in there
I just think he was frightened of being
jobless you've just put on the Shelf
I've forgotten about yeah and he didn't
want to feel as though they could manage
without him even though he knew that
it's the same with me
he's 62 though he doesn't need to be
that competitive with his staff no he
doesn't you could see the passion he's
had oh God 30 years yeah yeah easily
like I said there's not many that have
lasted that long
but it's about time he started to enjoy
it a little bit now
[Music]
tonight we're relaunching the Finnick
arms as a Great British pub
the real gravy campaign has done the
trick bookings have been pouring in all
day
on a normal Tuesday night Brian and
Elaine would be lucky to get 20
customers but there's already 88 booked
in for tonight's relaunch
[Music]
yeah we could maybe do it going on
towards half past
together a new menu of no-nonsense tasty
British pub favorites
there's hearty pea and ham soup
and the all-time classic a simple prawn
cocktails in the middle okay what's the
secret behind the pool cocktail good
prawns good prawns lovely merry Road
sauce
and a little bit of Apple
the apple and the lettuce yeah just
really make it nice and zesty all these
dishes use great ingredients prepared
simply and presented without fuss just
like this pressed ham terrine
when you think about something like a
puff you know it's rustic to keep the
food rusted yeah so in terms of
presentation dots and bits and
Bobs get it on there that's it end the
story
all the chefs have impressed me this
week but I think Karen's got the
maturity to run the kitchen so you're
gonna take the reins yeah you are yeah
and what happens if you start to change
things again what are you going to do
you put your foot down yeah yeah
time to show Brian and Elaine their new
menu I've replaced their complicated
fussy food with 25 classic Pub dishes
surprise surprise
simple straightforward honest British
pub food yeah and nothing too quirky I'm
well impressed roast River beef stunning
Yorkshire puddings
jug of gravy fish and chips
beautiful sausage and mash Lancashire
hot pot
an apple and blackberry crumble I'm
proud of what I can see the secret
behind this menu here and being
completely
traditional in terms of pub food it's
just the speed it can fly out of yeah
with two sittings in the dining room the
chefs will be under pressure but as
Brian and Elaine I'm worried about if
they can't relax and speed up the
service we'll be screwed
I'm shaking like a leaf inside
I don't know whether on this planet next
planet but I'm definitely on a
traditional Pub planet
they better be the pub is packed out
tonight but if Brian and Elaine are
going to start paying off their huge
debts this can't be a one-off
60 minutes from the start of the main
course game two roast beef let's keep it
nice
[Music]
cobwebs
the first time ever they're aiming to
fill the dining room twice over so they
can't waste time pouring wine or gravy
for their customers tonight
Mr Foster yes you've got him on table
falling
in this film three sorry
five minutes it's perfect gravy happy
with gravy Yorkshire pudding fantastic
so far so good the kitchen seems to be
coping well under pressure
just be careful all these main causes
flying out now dessert's next
[Applause]
time
they're only about 45 just go up to 50.
yeah over halfway yeah keep it going yes
but out front there's a disaster waiting
to happen it's 8 30 and they're slipping
into Old Habits the bar is full of
people waiting to be seated Brian and
Elaine haven't got the first customers
off the tables yet
um I'll get somebody to bring the bill
for you thanks we've got to get them out
of these tables now you know that's
where we've got to be firm now yes
but we finding harder transitions not a
restaurant is a pub yep so don't be
scared after one one hour 55 minutes
would you mind taking coffee in the bar
or can we have a drink in the bar change
those tables if you don't do that in the
next 15 minutes we're gonna be in the
have you got a bill for table that one
whichever one it is
pitch and go but at last the second
sitting at their tables
that's the hardest thing right now isn't
it gotta turn it around and for the
first time ever it's starting to run
like a pub
arms is buzzing
the real gravy is being lapped up and
traditional pub food has hit the spot I
had roast beef and it was so bad it's
with real gravy on it nice
lovely
it's Brian and Lane can keep up the pace
they might just pull this off
I mean pallets
it's a lot of excitement the adrenaline
is absolutely
pounding through me evening all
everything fine evening
it's been a huge success and finally the
pennies dropped for Brian he's realized
that the kitchen runs better without him
[Music]
I think the team have just been bloody
believable
they've done it I've not been there I've
not had to come in and where's this
where's that where the other and I am
just so proud of them all
well what a night
at times this week I've seriously
doubted it was possible but tonight the
fenik arms has been transformed from a
stuffy dining room into a vibrant packed
Pub
[Music]
how much money do we take
the till yep tells me we've done
2447. yes
2 000 pounds more than last Sunday lunch
Brian what does that tell you changing
the menu and doing it simpler yeah has
worked yeah well since I've been here as
a first nine I witnessed all of you
running a pub and I'm not going to come
back to what I came and saw a week ago
yes no you're not no no Chef whites no
knife rack nope nowhere near it no no
um there was one one little problem I
found a Barbie plate
please Eddie wrap it up in Clinton
dig a hole and hide it yes promise me
good man go
oh no Andy
[Applause]
[Music]
a month ago I left Brinley Lane running
a busy Pub I'm dying to find out if
they've kept it up
I'm on my way back to surprise them for
Sunday lunch
the car part's looking full always a
good sign
and the last Sunday I was here
they struggled to serve 22 people
good campaign for real grave is still
there
menu we can notice it this time
good evening good afternoon hello how
are you
having yourself yeah Veron D thank you
where's Brian
in the kitchen
why the is going on
what the are you doing in here
hello hello I thought you were doing the
Great Northern run
what are you doing dressing those
working
why because I haven't got anybody else
oh for God
and Chris's day off today so I'm on my
own
it turns out just one week after I left
Brian was back in the kitchen and Nathan
left to go back to college
I cannot believe I've just found you
back in the kitchen couldn't get any
stuff and we're just trying to recruit
to replace the one who went
what else is back truthfully before I
start rummaging around and looking for
it some of the plates oh no yep some of
the plates that was oh no
why because what you taught us was
listen to your customer oh here we go so
we did so your customers are saying
Bring Back Square plays no what they
wanted was the wow factor on the food
again that's what they wanted what do
you mean the wow facts on the phone it's
a herb Brian yes but if you're starting
to become a restaurant slowly within a
month you're destined for trouble we
went a little way down the road but you
kept the main new basically along the
lines of what you were saying
prawn cocktails still on there yes yeah
we've changed that we've changed that
yeah it's not in the wine glass no
um we've done it the way that we've
always done it and it sells
exceptionally well oh here we go
how did you used to sell the porn
cocktail before I put it in a glass
remind me uh scallop shell with it on a
scallop shell but it sells and the
customers like it Brian yeah prawns
don't live inside scallop shells nope
but they don't live inside glasses
either
oh
me now
the good news is that thanks to the real
gravy campaign in just one month Sunday
lunch takings have doubled and the
overall turnover is up by 30 percent
I'll start with a pull cocktail in the
scallop shell please yeah you haven't
got mashed potato pie around the outside
has it yes
so this is Brian's wow factor he really
is a stubborn old bat
it I'll do it myself
nice that's what I expect to see a prawn
cocktail
Ryan is making an incredible 250 liters
of gravy a week and I'm not surprised
people are flocking for this roast oh my
God the size of the portions
extraordinary nice gravy
and nothing farted around with yummy
lovely
yeah I don't think it's a beef a
Yorkshire pudding anywhere in the
country today that could have matched
what you served me for lunch
thank you so yeah
don't piss around with it you don't need
to
and whilst I'm slightly concerned that
you're back in the kitchen I hope it's
for a temporary it is time only because
if I talk to this lady
in six months time
God forbid and you've popped your
clogs in there on that stove
I'll be furious get out of there
run your Pub not your kitchen
please I will and I'm absolutely
confident that the way you have set us
up the way the menu is set up is going
to work look at me and tell me yes when
you let go yes because if you do let go
there's every chance this is going to
work you know that
Brian is full of surprises he's got a
new reason to log on to his computer
he's running the campaign for real gravy
website
[Music]
September 34 and a half thousand years
in one month in one month thirty four
and a half thousand yeah it's it's
fantastic thirty four and a half
thousand people logging on to find out
more about the clinic arms do me a favor
now start thinking about your next
compound
and I know what it should be
campaign for a real prawn cocktail
now you're taking the fish I'm not
taking
a piss seven in a scallop shell
good luck thanks very much thank you
scallop shells in a prawn cocktail
out
30 years
Running a Restaurant in Spain should be
a dream but for 26 year old Lawrence
Davey it's a nightmare this is
critical that's not cool that's raw I'm
not gonna taste that yet but it looks
burnt
he's in the five Place yeah one two
three four five the first thing I've
spotted is dog
and if I can't put him back on his feet
he'll be on the next plane home where's
one of you gonna step forward with a
pair of bollocks when are you guys gonna
stop around with excuses because
that was shocking
[Music]
Costa Del Sol Spain for the first time
I'm abroad on a special mission to
rescue a failing British run restaurant
during the summer months thousands of
Brits will invade the Mediterranean
Coastline and spend their hard-earned
cash
[Music]
for the masses more and more British
restaurants are opening on the Costa
this Championship sausage and ships fish
and chips barbecue chicken
get it right here and you could be
sitting on a gold mine how many portions
of chips would you serve well per week
roughly we'd probably do in excess of
100 portions a day so seven eight
hundred a week how are the chips very
good yeah what would you do if I banned
chips from here
do not come
and it's good English
is there anything on the Costa that
doesn't come with chips one more steak
garnish please and a lamb shank I'll get
that
one Russian owner who thought he'd
spotted a gap in the market his 26 year
old Brit Lawrence Davey
[Music]
18 months ago he borrowed 40 000 pounds
from his dad and opened La para the
Biryani 500 meters off the beach in the
coastal Resort of Neha this restaurant
has great potential to be very
successful and very popular and it's a
great location but I've been doing it
for a year and a half now and I haven't
seen any success whatsoever
armed with his catering degree and a few
years managing nightclubs and
restaurants Lawrence designed a
Mediterranean menu with a Twist to lure
the Brits away from the egg and chips
my particular favorite King prawns in
garlic and ginger and chili served with
our signature chocolate sauce on the
side it's not very popular
which kind of proves The Adventurous
side of my customers
with the prawns in chocolate sauce
failing to win round the Brits he lost
22 Grand in his first year
I don't know whether I went about it
wrong way or whether people don't want
it or are ready for it I don't know
since then he's broadened his menu to a
massive 72 dishes cooking everything
from Chinese chicken to Turkish kebabs
I've even served chicken nuggets and
chips to an adult and I absolutely hate
it I really hate it
but with takings down on last year he'll
be lucky to survive the summer let alone
the winter
I'm in Spain to stop lapada from going
under
when did it start going really quiet
when did it
um we suddenly snapped about September
last year it suddenly just went you know
the life as if the light was switched
off
um and it was just it just died
um ever since then we've been losing
money what do you know about restaurants
before you opened it um I said then my
degree did my internship in terms of
that's training in terms of sure it was
a nightclub in Cheltenham and then
became restaurant manager of a big
restaurant in London and that's when I
really said you know I'm doing it I'm
doing really well I'm succeeding in
everything in what I'm doing what can I
do it for myself they need it they need
me in nurka they really need me to do
great stuff and now you're 26 yep and in
the yeah how bad in the
I'm a hundred and two thousand
Euros in debt 102 000 Euros yeah so 70
grand yeah so the Noose is really on
your neck I've either got to make it
here or go back to London and
paying back to my father
the singers of the shoes are what
would you say signature dishes um we do
a great prawns dish with a chocolate
sauce which I've done from day one
prawns with chocolate sauce with
chocolate sauce yeah so starch and
dessert at the same time well me
that sounds different
right let's see what a former nightclub
manager has to offer the Brits abroad
extraordinary menu and then different
themes Flamenco Burger night Kebab menu
Chinese chicken or pork confused so what
the going on
if I'd wanted a Chinese I would have
gone to one but I'm in Spain let's hope
Lawrence is signature dish of prawns in
chocolate sauce gives me the flavor of
the med cool down
it's worse than a chocolate sauce it's
um hot
over spicy chili chocolate sauce but
that's just
stupid arrogance really trying to match
something that's never gonna go
if that's how Lauren serves up fresh
local prawns then I wonder what he's got
in store for my fillet steak Kebab well
he's gone for the Kebab which is well
wow factor dish when you know it comes
out on the hook so I think he gets to
see that bit of what we do yeah is that
how they're always served oh Jesus
me
it's the kind of thing you imagine
Jordan eating with the hands
behind her back is someone taking the
piss how can you expect something like
that
to be cooked at the same time
a fillet steak kebab
may not sound that exciting but it
should taste delicious
and that in terms of presentation
if I thought my Kebab was overcooked
that's nothing compared to what's
happening to my creme catalana
burn the kitchen down
I mean well it's certainly burned it
looks like a ice hockey puck
look at it
comes with an appointment at the dentist
tomorrow morning at 9 30. me
it's liquid and it's it's ruined so when
you sat with all these fresh ingredients
on your doorstep
and the climate they've got
the simpler it is
the better it's going to be
unfortunately they've got more
complicated and tried to be clever and
completely lost the plant
foreign
rule for running a restaurant in Spain
is don't ruin good produce with fancy
gimmicks good food will always sell
itself Lawrence's novelty dishes may
have been designed to turn heads but all
it's done for me is turn my stomach
prawns
the flavor that prawns was extraordinary
fresh vibrant why do you want to
around and put chocolate sauce on there
um because I don't want to be boring I
want to be excited I thought it was
hideous it didn't work
but then I came to this schlong
at Kebab have you actually ever sat at
the table and watched six customers with
this donkey's dick swinging in
front of their face it's hilarious
well that is that that is you know it's
a talking point it's it's a it's a wow
fact that's a wow factor yeah it's a
fillet steak Yeah it was tough as old
boots I don't know but you know before
you start mouthing up let me
just show you a cube that big and acute
that big I'm not gonna cook the same
time
oh me here we go can I just finish
the sentence first Sinbad and then you
can come back on me in a minute
that out there was embarrassing so it's
painful if it's painful for me
and you're 102 000 Euros in the
knows how you sleep at night
you know I feel so about the whole
thing
but deep down I really wanted to work
and I want my dream to come true you're
in Spain
you don't have to be that quirky
to be good
I'll see you in the morning
I've certainly got my work cut out
I get the feeling nightclub boy isn't
going to give up his novelty dishes
without a fight
prawns in chocolate sauce
[Music]
for the first time I'm in Spain on a
mission to turn around a failing British
run restaurant
former Nightclub and restaurant manager
Lawrence Davey came to Neha to conquer
the Costa
thought his novelty dishes of swinging
kebabs and prawns and chocolate sauce
would win over the egg and chips loving
Brits
but the Brits aren't biting and after
sampling his food I can see why last
thought is going to come over to Spain
and take it by storm he opened up at 24
years of age using his dad's
money he thought his balls were bigger
than the mountains and he thought he's
going to bring a Mediterranean twist
with a difference he's got all the
gimmicks and he thinks by being simple
it's too plain for Spain but you'd never
think he's 102 000 Euros in debt
it's mid-august and Neha is flooded with
British tourists
restaurants on the Costa will make a
quarter of the annual profit in August
alone
even lapada will be busy and boy do they
need to be
okay two tickets three potatoes were on
us one prawn cocktail tonight is my
chance to see how lapara copes with a
full service with Lawrence cooking the a
la carte dishes alone in the kitchen his
sous chef Norm is grilling the kebabs
and steaks on the Terrace barbecue
this is your little dungeon then this is
yours this is where they locked me into
the evening yeah
Lawrence might not have much experience
as a chef but he has been a restaurant
manager
maybe his skill lies in employing the
best staff to do the best jobs
this goes up and down so I can
higher or lower it according to cooking
temperatures for example it's a very
modern updated barbecue yes it's more
like a torture rack for foods
torture rack for food he's not joking
[Music]
I'm in my book I think that's well done
now
suffering on top of the grill are 10
Chicken Kebabs that have yet to be
ordered why'd you cook it so early on
because I've only just done them are
they cooked yeah they're coming off now
so not really Barb if you know they're
almost like poached well they're poached
on a barbecue when I sealed him off
poached them and then finished them on
the barbecue again
kebabs grilled poached and left sitting
in the heat they're hardly fresh off the
barbecue
but according to Norm there's plenty of
life left in them yet I usually use them
tomorrow for one day so I will use them
tomorrow they want these ones that I've
cooked are you out your mind
I know I was letting myself go there but
I've told you the truth I respect your
honesty
but do me a favor yeah
don't even serve those to the Stray Cats
after service tonight let alone the
customers
thank you
[Music]
rule number two for running a restaurant
in Spain tourists might have holiday
insurance but that doesn't mean you can
give them Spanish tummy when cooking on
a barbecue don't take risks
does he honestly serve the
barbecued kebabs the following night yes
it's your business
and barbecues are the best of times are
not the things to be played with
in a way that it's a toy
and why don't you stop him serving
I don't know Norm's Norm he's in a world
of his own
and as night falls the world of lapara
becomes even darker
Norm looks like he's preparing for a
wake and after seeing his kebabs I
wouldn't be surprised it's like we're at
midnight mass here yeah I know
what's that
the Dynamo talks isn't it all right
let's see what's going on here right
cooking my Clockwork torch it doesn't
get any more Mickey Mouse than this
you need more light out here what's the
cost of a light bulb no I don't feel
like snake
well done Philly yeah
yeah we haven't got that so you have no
I wouldn't finish take about an hour ago
and it hasn't turned up yet I'm just I'm
study starving hungry
the food may not be Spanish but there's
certainly something Manana about manager
Alex's service I've been sat there over
now for the main cause he's cooking it
and the plates are in there yeah this
fragmented service is horrendous
you know that
is it normal for customers to wait this
long
right so yeah I can't go any quicker
than I'm going I'm going as quick as I
possibly can
it's not as if I'm not trying
you can try as hard as he likes but no
Chef can cook 72 different dishes on his
own
to keep up with these orders Lawrence
has thrown everything onto his Plancha
Grill
it doesn't get any lazier than that
depending on that plaster girl to cook
everything from door Rod to
kebabs to chatea brianda and then this
lazy Med veg that is the most
disgusting way I've ever seen
good ingredients bust her eyes he might
as well open a greasy spoon and
serve egg and chips because that's
disgusting
huge menu for lazy cooking and the
customers waiting hours for Food
Lawrence has lost the plot I don't think
I've actually quite ever been faced with
something
that already so early on looks like such
an uphill struggle
especially when you're charging
money for it
it's day three and the hard work starts
here stinks if understand any chance of
getting a putter out of the shed this
place needs a fresh start
folks on the floor glass everywhere
cigarettes
chips dog that way I've seen some
unsavory things in my time Alex two
seconds
but dog in the dining area is
Unforgivable
first thing I've spotted is dog
that's not good enough
are you happy with that no I'm not happy
no it's disgusting yeah that's the third
time I've seen it
rule number three Running a Restaurant
in Spain isn't a holiday there's a
laid-back attitude the fact that we're
in Spain so we can afford to be
semi-casual because we're dealing with
tourists no are we we're running a
restaurant and the discipline here can
be the same in Paris could be the same
in London could be anywhere and thinking
that it's good to work in a dirty
kitchen or a dirty restaurant with dog
shedding forget it
manager Alex might be Lawrence is best
mate from college but he's clearly left
his standards back in Britain
if dog goes unnoticed there is no
surprise the kitchen is dripping in
Greece
I was used a lot yeah
you put fresh oil in it all the time
yeah of course you do yeah how often and
once a week the oil would last a lot
longer if you got rid of all this stuff
here look
there you go that's what you're cooking
out of yeah heavy time putting fresh oil
in there is making all difference
that's large
[Music]
with the Russian having a much needed
deep clean there's something else I want
to clear up
last February Lawrence put on a
Valentine's dinner for the local Donkey
Sanctuary charity 100 British expats
paid 30 pound ahead for a fundraising
meal
Rumor Has It Lawrence made a complete
ass of it
how bad did it go I mean was it um it
was a complete it was absolutely
disaster in what way the food was
overcooked dry tasteless what was the
menu
um we did the chicken liver parfait
which wasn't made until the morning so I
had no time to set a chicken dish wraps
of serrano ham baked in the oven the
chicken was so dry it was like cardboard
did he give it to him on the house no
you challenged them yeah you know
no wonder they haven't been back
rule number four when you're running a
restaurant in Spain don't piss off the
locals
when the tourists have gone home the
local expats account for 80 of your
takins in the winter months without them
a British restaurant in Spain can't
survive
[Music]
I'm heading into hostile territory to
make peace with the natives
I'm off to the local Donkey Sanctuary
and hopefully after meeting them I'd
want to see if there's any chance they
actually come back and give the
restaurant one more chance can I
see us all I know about donkeys is
they're stubborn this isn't going to be
easy
and I'm fascinated to get to the bottom
of what actually happened on that
fundraising dinner in terms of big event
I mean not very funny it was the sort of
meal that you're all waiting the next
day to have a very nasty trip into the
toilet what was the menu the menu was
Pate initially yep um which was frozen
you needed a blowtorch Frozen on the
plate Frozen yeah Frozen on the plate
main course was chicken stuffed with
banana supposed to be served with
asparagus yes banana and asparagus it
was supposed to be his signature dish
not another one with a Twist on
there this became cancerous isn't it
because it spread like wildfire across
the town
arrogant about the whole thing if he
thinks he can survive in a small town
like this with that attitude it's got
another thing coming have you been back
since
is it any small fraction of possibility
if you could just think about it if I
could convince you just to put one foot
in the door it'd be a big help I
promise us we don't have to eat
chocolate covered prawns
charging a local charity for a bad meal
smacks of unbelievable arrogance
Lawrence might have come to Spain to
offer the Brits something different but
so far all he's given them is
pretentious novelty food
I'm going to give him a taste of his own
medicine
[Music]
of that
smell first maybe a little taste
first up a chocolate and prawn smoothie
based on Lawrence's signature dish
what's that taste of Lawrence chocolate
yeah it's not chocolate bigger man and
then it tastes like um cookies cookies
taste that one again thanks I think it's
horrible
okay
um
next a chicken and banana smoothie based
on the dish he served at the Donkey
Sanctuary dinner
there's a texture in there which
is quite stringy
stringy it says stringy texture it's a
banana and string oh man banana is
something horrible in it again mine
falls off
the first one
it's prawns and chocolate could
you taste the prawn there
um well you know something in there that
was
not very nice you didn't get it what I'm
trying to say if you've got the best of
prawns let them Taste of prawn
don't let them taste off prawn and
chocolate
this is the most painful smoothie
because it's the chicken and banana and
it's the the dish that managed
to piss off the locals at the donkey
sanctuary's charitable event
what the were you thinking about
putting banana on chicken
together
tell me so I can help you okay
um it was just you know using like a
South American kind of inferences in
roasting chicken but you didn't
tell me the truth about the banana no
and I'm a chef
and I've done my homework before
I got here
and let food taste of what it should
it's not just mixing prawns with
chocolate and chicken with banana that's
the problem it's the other 70 dishes on
Lawrence's huge menu sit down
I want to replace it with a dozen dishes
that you can cook easily to stop the
tourist waiting hours for their dinner
have you come to terms with you know
trying to restrict the menu every time I
try to think about it I think of the
people that have asked for this those
particular items and why I shouldn't
take them off I did get some return
customers so
I'm actually doing something right but
where are these then because
I've been here for three nights and the
Trot and I don't see the return
business
you give me the impression in such a
short period of time I've known you that
I've got
a young man that's playing with his
dad's money trying to run a
restaurant
that's the impression I get
well I think that's wrong because I
believe in what I'm doing is right if I
didn't I wouldn't be doing it I couldn't
do this menu on my own
with 72 dishes on there
I couldn't do it
because you're not a proper chef
so if you're not a proper Chef then
don't try and cook out your box
and unless that's gonna sink in
and stay in your mind I've got no chance
Lawrence is refusing to reduce his huge
menu but it's the only way he'll ever go
with a busy restaurant it's time to
prove my point
[Music]
for tonight's service I've advised the
three course Mediterranean menu that
will fly out the kitchen and get
customers served quickly
a gazpacho soup
barbecued chicken with a warm potato
salad
and a roasted caramelized Peach
what's the twist there isn't a Twist
it's all local that's it there's
no twist there yep tonight customers
will order from Lawrence's a la carte
menu but when he falls behind he'll
switch to mine and that will show him
how quick he can serve customers I just
want him to have that emergency menu at
the Forefront of his mind so he's ego
apart get that back in London having to
concentrate on sort of accomplishing a
fully booked service with no complaints
got an order for chocolate prawns
he said you know earlier no one wants to
buy chocolate prawns he thinks he's
stupid idea first order that came in
chocolate prawns and carrot soup so um
it's nine o'clock and the orders from
Lawrence's huge menu of 72 dishes are
now flooding in
but it's already starting to go wrong
medium yes yeah look no no it's raw it's
not pink it's raw it's raw it's red raw
all I want you to do is just cook a
bad problem yeah please
right you're in control yeah yeah that
I'm not gonna taste that yet but it
looks burnt
Lawrence needs to push the button now
and replace his menu with my menu if
he's to avoid a repeat of last night's
Fiasco
you want to push the button no no
seriously no no seriously yeah no you're
sure yes yeah yeah hey this is nothing
to do with your bollocks and size your
is it no Lawrence's reluctance to
use my emergency menu means it's the
customers who suffer and if I'm dead
honest with you the lamb is everyone's
saying the Lamb's bone dry it's
appalling really really is appalling yep
yeah way up to that one there
that's not cool that's Raw
but the complaint was very cold yeah you
know it's cold because it's what that's
why
when meals start coming back Lawrence
finally cracks
right you're right yeah you are yes yeah
I've called your menu away you've called
it away yeah it's all done all you have
to do is call it away hey a normal's
just got to put the chicken on
the barbecue nothing more yes thank you
for pushing the button
pushing out my emergency menu should
have been idiot proof but they've left
it too late and in the hands of Dumb and
Dumber it descends into fast
it's like putting 25 minutes ago yeah
and I'm still trying to move because
I've had to turn food out I can't stop
starting to start I'm doing my next door
I just asked you yeah yeah
I'm looking for the cloth lines
it was the time you need to pull your
finger out now is right now you know
that hey yeah I've got two pork kebabs
to make but why are we serving pork
burger when we've got the emergency menu
on I don't know ask the waiter
there's little point in asking
restaurant manager Alex
[Music]
he's so confused as to who's ordered
what he's now serving food to tables
with no one on them
[Applause]
[Music]
this place right now is the biggest
in Spain it's
embarrassing Costa Del at its
best
it's the worst meal we've ever had
quarter to 12 noon we got here at half
past nine we just finished the main
course so it has been a long way
with customers born out from waiting
meal's been sent back
and now refund's been handed out
surely even Lawrence can see that by
sticking to his stupid menu he's only
got himself to blame
I'm speechless so I I I don't know what
to say let's get to the Crux
flowers
um I think no one was put on the far too
much pressure tonight you know he your
menu made him plate up his own plates
and do the starters and the cold soups
out there on the barbie and he couldn't
manage slowing down too much
um you're telling me that my menu
him up on the grill he couldn't he
couldn't do it
couldn't deal with what
bowl of soup out it was already
made for him it was when are you guys
gonna stop around with excuses
when's one are you gonna step forward
with a pair of bollocks and give him
some honesty
because I know where you were because
that was shocking
let me tell you something
you made a good decision you
pushed the button whether you like it or
not it was too late an hour and
a half late so whose fault was
it now
chef
I'm out of it
yourself
[Music]
well he wanted me to be honest I told
him what I thought
yeah maybe I should have left with the
home with his whole menu
but that's hindsight
and hindsight I should never even done
this project
[Music]
it's day five and the storm clouds over
La Para
[Music]
I've never felt as bad about a
restaurant as I did last night and when
I walked out I wasn't sure I'd be coming
back
just when I thought things couldn't get
any worse
there was a break-in and nearly four
thousand pounds were stolen from the
premises overnight
yeah fine
um
first of all sorry to hear about the
news yeah this is not good it's not good
at all
how much was it five and a half thousand
years five and a half thousand dollars
well she's not much of a guard
though Apes
um and where's the where's the safe
it's not so much a safe but a cash tin
in a filing cabinet
been jimmied here down the sides it's
still locked I haven't moved or touched
anything this is how I found it when I
came down
we've then got the the money box inside
here
unbelievable they've left the small
notes they just took the big ones and
I'm not being funny it's the filing
cabinet
why would you leave five and a half
Grand in there
the most important rule for any
restaurant owner anywhere in the world
is always put your takings in the bank
I've got to think long and hard weather
I can actually continue without that
money and now that may be the Clincher
that you know
to make it
it's not just a failing restaurant I'm
dealing with but I don't know about the
book is flight home if ever there was a
time for Lawrence to realize that I'm
here to help it's now it's your pride
that you've got to stop worrying
about
because how proud are you gonna
feel how Malaga airport where
your bags what you're gonna do
what
what no seriously hello what the
are you gonna do
yeah go home will you cop
between your legs
yeah yeah
and what ring your mates tell them what
big you've been in
Spain I don't go through that kind of
to help turn a
restaurant around I can't do it without
you
[Music]
I've only one more chance to get through
to Lawrence and get him listening to me
[Music]
and go into a bull ring without taking
clear instruction from someone who knows
what they're talking about
[Music]
yeah
listen to this man for the next five
minutes because
um he's going to show you some very very
crucial moves
to God he ditches the arrogance and
listens to Matador Raphael more than
he's listened to me
big Tesla now he's got to stand
with his own two feet and show me as the
Spanish would say yokohanas
show me you've got a pair of bollocks
and use them
have you got your gohanas sit yeah
no problemo where
where currently tucked up inside
[Music]
okay you now stay out the way watch
out
where's your kohana
oh it's a it's just a stop
I don't think um Spanish pills like me
very much
what am I doing oh yeah
one thing he doesn't eat now
you're stubbornness
[Music]
come on
get off your ass come on get up
[Music]
I'm not doing that
come on get out of here come on
with Lawrence carefully listening to
Raphael's expert advice he starts to get
the hang of it
I won one
[Music]
rule number six Running a Restaurant in
Spain is a risky business it pays to
listen to some expert advice
scary now yeah how do you feel
um I feel like your Point's been proven
in a very big way you have a big pair of
gohanas
now just use it
well done get some water yeah
hell
now I've got Lawrence listening I need
to get him cooking like a proper Chef
every night no one's Cooks everything on
this planter Grill to save time as a
result it all tastes the same fishy meat
and Meaty veg
for me
whilst Lawrence finds an egg on the
plunger Grill I'm cooking mine in a
non-stick Frying Pan
um
I want to teach him how his lazy way of
cooking is tainting everything he serves
up
that's just with an egg yeah what I'm
trying to get through is all that there
yeah
is what
carbonized food food thank you ages and
ages carbonized and all
what you do now is start thinking about
cooking in pans yeah I'm going to show
Lawrence that in the time it takes him
to cook a whole sea bream on his grill
foreign
Mediterranean sauce
what I'm trying to do Lawrence yeah is
make your life easier you know
that yeah and whilst I'm still waiting
for yours I'm just gonna an orange
a lemon
a pink grapefruit fish basil
are you cooked yet almost
out
and on
now I'm not trying to be some jumped up
smiley ass little I'm
just trying to explain you're busting
your bollocks the wrong way around
because I am not going to listen
to Tom dickinery telling me they
want to sit and compete with
that or sit and eat that I know which
one you can do 10 times quicker and a
thousand times better
don't be scared to use a pan okay do you
understand he's drilled into me my pride
and you know my arrogance is really shut
through and have been a bit of an ass
about it and a bit stubborn and you know
I'm I'm really now excited that he's
here I really want to learn and and get
this place moving
the penny might have dropped
but now I've only got two days to put
things right out with the old yeah in
with a new bin number yeah we're
short of call tonight
did Lawrence finally letting go of his
huge menu it's time for a new beginning
in its place I've created a small
Mediterranean menu using local produce
five starters including figs and Serrano
ham and watermelon with feta cheese and
six Mains including a pan-fried sea
bream and a barbecued chicken on a warm
potato salad
actually cooking properly feels
absolutely fantastic at last limited
menu fresh ingredients
the menu will offer Brit something
authentic fresh and above all quick to
prepare
and in reducing 72 dishes to 15 the
service couldn't be any simpler for
restaurant manager Alex so okay what
about this table here 830 booking I've
just taken order now okay good okay
let's go here the menu's simpler a lot
easier we can do volume now now we've
got a chance to put the thing
right
it's my final night and it's the
relaunch of LA parra's new menu
I've only got one shot at this and I
can't afford any mistakes
changing you tonight yeah you're you're
you're coming off that barbecue yeah I
want you connected
for the owner as a sous chef okay that's
my decision I'm sticking to it
I'm putting sous chef Norm in the
kitchen prepping cold starters
and pop washer Tom will take his place
on the barbecue
it's a gamble but I'm confident Tom will
send the meat out cooked
and all you have to do is take the
chicken off the barbecue and put it onto
the plate and send it yeah sure good
okay sir this evening isn't just about
launching a new menu it's about large
regaining his reputation with the
British expat community
six months ago he hosted a fundraising
dinner for the local Donkey Sanctuary
serving Frozen starters and chicken
stuffed with banana it was a fiasco
tonight I convinced them to come back
it's very nerve-wracking having them
here because I know how much I upset
them last time and I know how much
distaste they have through the
restaurant in general and it's really
nerve-wracking for me to be able to know
that I've got to cook for them and cook
them really really well tonight will be
the test whether or not the food's
edible that would be a good start
yeah
with customers getting their food on
time the relaunch is off to a good start
[Music]
fish with fries a lot better than last
year yeah
phenomenal nothing's come back having
this cooked beautifully yeah to be
honest so far it's been a breath of
fresh air
right donkey sanction just sat down yes
yep okay
that table like a time bomb
the starters arrived for the Donkey
Sanctuary
but just when I thought it was all going
to plan Alex has forgotten to serve the
wine how can we put the starters down
without serving the wine
um of all tables come on
at nine o'clock the restaurant's full
but bizarrely there's a backlog of
people waiting for tables
it's Alex's responsibility to get them
seated but he's flapping around like a
headless chicken
what's going on with this table
is waiting the bar for so long table six
Table Six yeah I double books that you
see at the start of the night I had to
tell them that you know we need to have
the table back who did you tell we need
the table back the customer the customer
what about the kitchen
they need to know first because they've
got to cook it yeah so they leave your
answer
for some bizarre reason Alex has got
tables double booked within an hour no
one can eat anything within an hour
embarrassing I mean embarrassing
Alex has simply got greedy in thinking
they can turn tables around in an hour
as a result people are turning up for
the reservations but have nowhere to sit
and in the Kitchen Lawrence is now
struggling with a backlog of orders
the Doncaster table on top of all that
Alex has now gone into meltdown
Alex
you can do it
I know you're waiting on me and I really
appreciate this this is critical
Canal go come on Alex please
we waited for 40 minutes for starter
then sat with dirty plates for 45
minutes and then we were asked to leave
the table because the next lot of guests
arrived five pages yeah one two three
four five five
although Under Pressure laws is at least
coping with my reduced menu yep your
three Serrano three watermelon yep
put these out
and only be grateful that Lance got the
Donkey Sanctuary main courses out before
the hit the fan
all right very nice I mean it was a lot
nicer than chicken banana I must admit
the food
I think everybody's quite pleased with
the food if he can come up with this
sort of deal yes we'll be back again but
the service leaves quite a little bit to
be desired I think a lot more work on
the service
it's the end of the evening and
Lawrence's cooking has been a success
Alex is double booking madness has let
everyone down
we're So Close Alex
so close
you can do better I know I can do better
you can do better
turn around and tell him that he's
paying your salary
thank you
tough nine a real tough night 87
covers and it was a struggle and the
service was pretty dismal
however the Donkey Sanctuary have
confirmed they're going to come back
that speaks volumes that means the local
community are now back on their side and
quite frankly you can't ask for a more
crucial time for them to support it
because we're just about to come out the
summer season and into the
winter and without their support they
won't get through the winter
thank you
in six days I've finally seen a change
at lepada but once I've gone Lawrence is
only four weeks until the end of the
season to make the money that will help
him survive the winter
remember
do not cut corners and don't make a
ass of yourself
look a start reminder
to make sure that standards never slip
don't make your ass yourself
that's gone that is gone
goodbye okay
my only hope La Paris doors will still
be open when I return
[Music]
in the summer I spent a week at La para
the biriana on the Costa Del Sol
it was holiday hell that's not cool
that's Raw
former nightclub manager Lawrence Davey
was up to his eyes in debt
he had swinging kebabs someone taking
the piss
prawns in chocolate sauce I thought it
was hideous
and his dishes with a Twist had pissed
off the Brits
really is appalling
Lawrence was so stubborn he wouldn't
give up his huge menu without a fight no
you're sure yes yeah yeah hey this is
nothing to do with the Apollo because
what size your is it
after knocking some sense into him I
created a set menu of just 15 authentic
Mediterranean dishes
and on the launch night we won back the
local expat trade that Lawrence had lost
if he can come up with this sort of deal
yes we'll be back again
[Music]
four weeks later I'm back on the Costa
it's late September and most of the
tours have packed up and gone home
the beachfront restaurants are deserted
feels like a ghost town
I only hope La para is faring better
good to see you thank you yeah how's the
monthly busy very very busy ready yeah
good almost double last year so that's
great news good to see you you
too have you been really good yeah it's
been great yes busy it has been busy and
you're working hard yes yes less
flustered yes more organized well
organized we're happy we're
communicating and what's the special
Kebab tonight
uh the vegetable Kebab is in the bin
great donkey dick kebabs are off the
menu
I'm still in the kitchen preparing cold
starters good to see you man and out on
the Terrace is Tom the former pot washer
now promoted as the barbecue chef
and enormous things out here again or is
this your domain
is your domains
but best of all Lawrence is no longer
cooking on the plunger Grill
I haven't used it in about three weeks
you haven't used the Pancho Grill thank
you
I really mean that yeah you must
miss it no no I did I did about a week I
kept on going back to it yeah
where's my steak Yeah
considering it's the end of the season
the para is reassuringly busy
everything seems to be running more
efficiently
it's an area of calmness around it and
yeah it's a nice Buzz which is lovely
everything's gleaming it's spotless
the menu is no longer the size of a
telephone directory it's one page and
there are even some new dishes for me to
try
I was a little bit cocky and that he'd
love my food when he first got here this
time around I know that I really really
want to impress him now with these
dishes if I can't impress him now then
you know I've really it up here
we are who is the squid and shoot sir
thank you for my starter I've chosen
barbecue squid and chorizo sausage on a
bed of rocket
it's nicely cooked it's not too chewy
and the Cerrito sausage just gives it
that little spice that squid needs
and that's what you come to Spain for
dishes like this
for my main course I've chosen sea bass
on a bed of cream leeks one of the new
dishes minorities Autumn menu
[Music]
there's just no comparison to what I was
fed a month ago where it's just really
nice clean simple honest food and that's
what this place needed without any
stupid twists four weeks ago
Lawrence was 75 000 in debt equivalent
to 102 000 Euros and lapara was on the
verge of closing down
what really shocked me about tonight's
dinner
there's
I can't believe it was the same guy that
was cooking my dinner a month ago
that was delicious
it's absolute pleasure to cook in here
now and I you know I'm not angry I'm not
upset I'm just you know cooking the food
I love cooking and and seeing empty
plates come back clean and happy
customers leaving the restaurant
you took 3 000 Euros this time of year
ago now you're on 9 000 years what have
you knocked off on the debt
um I've knocked off
13 000 Euros
since you were here Cash Cash already
yeah yeah what do you need to do a night
to stay open during the winter how many
killers during the winter of 20 20.
so already tonight with 33 or 34 in for
dinner
yeah we're we're not home and dry but
we're making sure great Headway
don't you dare stop yeah and
every time you think of stopping turn on
the plunger Grill yeah deep fry your
vegetables and hit them
on there never again good night
Tom
was valid for money delicious
straightforward local produce cooked
properly and he's not trying to be too
clever and if you can continue
doing that he's got a strong chance of
surviving the winter and opening up next
season ready to attack it with
some money in the bank thank God for
that the penny has finally
dropped
thank you
[Music]